[Music]
okay
three two one
action action one action two
action free action anthony this story
takes place in spain
earlier today he told me he spent two
months in spain
madrid or barcelona madrid
what damn you spent two straight months
there yeah and your spanish good
and all you got was just that that
eastelle accent
little like i've been hanging around a
lot of easter eggs
i'm just pointing out what i hear i at
the end of the day is los angeles
from the bottom of washington from
orange county actually before
you're santa anna's actually you are
actually i am
no way actually why i don't know what a
paco
really you're from bonaparte yeah i was
born in santa ana
santa ana next to santa claus
right i know you shouldn't be saying
that i shouldn't say what
don't say where you were born cut that
out because it's a security question oh
[ __ ]
oh i never used that i only used my
first high school
no just kidding like i had a second high
school
he's had a few of them did you go to
kennedy high school i didn't i was
supposed to because that's border park
right canada
you're going to park yeah but it's also
born park high so it really depends on
the district
a lot of my friends from orange county
did a lot of drugs well
from there we're going to segue into
this what is it how do you segue
well i can't that's why i have to leave
fuller
nice an actual segway that's right
okay so this story has nothing to do
with drugs or
segways a little bit of space okay
anyway the story here
is a mother of one has been forced
to shave her head after a random man
stuck a hat on her head filled with glue
oh it sucks it caused her to have second
degree burn oh
[ __ ] what kind of glue did they have
that it didn't dry up
well i'm not sure exactly what kind but
they were saying that you know it and
it ended up creating second what did i
say degree
second degree what kind of hat chemical
bond i don't know look at that
these are great questions and i really
do you know any of the
insignificant details please the brand
one of the colors
you know she reminded me of matilda do
you guys remember matilda
it was a hat similar to this yeah or
he's like
haha you know and then it's like
i can't get this off ah viper's diffused
to the head
what why did this random man put it on
her in the first place okay
so it's crazy i mean that is a [ __ ] up
thing to do you know
he's sitting at home and he's putting
crazy glue all up on his [ __ ] getting
bald that's why
so that's his way to getting at she's
like crazy with like pepper though
you know for the burn well you got to
get close i don't think that's like you
got to get close or it's one of those
trick shots where you do one of these
and you [ __ ] land it on his head
tricks yeah like d tricks
and it has to be fast because the glue
dries quick yeah they have to
have to put on right
all right so let me tell you what
happened like in the moment of when it
happened it's tragic but it sounds funny
okay so this stranger this stranger
buzzed her apartment doorbell at around
9 00 a.m
claiming that he had a present for her
oh [ __ ] not too early so she
saw that this man was holding a bouquet
of flowers in his hand and so she buzzed
him into her building
and then she says once at the door of my
house and in front of my eight-year-old
son he threw the flowers at my feet
called me a son of a [ __ ] and pulled
the hat over my head he ran away my son
was shouting very scared and i rushed to
the bathroom to clean up my head
and asked my son to call the police or
friends so then after arriving to the
hospital
um she had to be she had to be treated
for second-degree burns
that was caused by the glue and abrasive
substances
filled with glass and so the doctors so
my
her name is marcela and marcella's
originally from colombia when she was at
the hospital the doctor
informed her that these kinds of attacks
are common in colombia oh it's colombian
and it's called doing the shampoo and it
is commonly ordered by jealous wives
after finding out their husbands had
cheated on them or because they
envy the other woman and so marcelo was
saying that
that she owns a beauty clinic uh beauty
place
they call it a clinic so i just use
their words beauty clinic located in the
same building
as her house and so she says that before
this attack she was receiving a lot
of suspicious calls from an anonymous
woman
with a colombian accent and she said
that the woman had called about a month
ago asking to make an appointment
at her salon and then she was requesting
the location so then
two weeks later that's when she saw a
suspicious man in the building holding a
phone and asked
and asked uh and so she ended up asking
her neighbors if they were expecting
someone because she thought that was
really weird
but they were like no we don't know this
pool so then it turns out that
that was a guy that ended up coming back
and attacking her
and with a hat and so
that led to her having to shave her head
so now she does
you think it's like beauty wars like the
salon wars
her rival is like she's making too many
girls too hot
or whatever who knows the reason why i
mean i was curious too and i'm like well
if the reason
is because she's involved with the man
or this woman
is jealous of her like i'm kind of
curious like what's her love life
situation is she involved with some dude
that maybe she got a lot of boyfriends
she's like i don't know which one of my
boyfriends got a jealous girlfriend
is what ended up happening like looking
afterwards
that's why i said i know the color
because it's yellow the hat wasn't quite
stuck it was all what is that the glue
yeah it's more like a two-part epoxy
yeah you would know how long does it
take for it like
instantly grow out yeah no yeah i mean
she has the shape it's pretty badass i
want to shave my head
yeah so whoa
poor lady i know yeah so like oh she
looked good
she does look good she rocks this rocket
the burns make sense now they said the
boobs i thought you said boobs too and
i'm like
the boobs also make sense but the burns
make sense because when you combine a
two-part epoxy it gets hot
it's really hot you know what else
complicatedly fuses oh
what'd you say you know what else it's
hot her boobs yeah
yeah she looks really [ __ ] good bald
she should keep that style
she looks part asian or something mm-hmm
colombian
that's who she is living in spain go to
skin oh
so it was another colombian in spain
yes it's a colombian war it seems like
that that's the case it's a glue hat war
doing the shampoo that's common i know
i'm like holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] scary
so scary like what defines common like
how many a year
i mean they probably heard it enough to
when they see it they recognize what it
is why would you open a door for someone
at nine in the morning
well because they have flowers for you
yeah but you should have a gun pointed
at them that's weird
okay i want to send them something well
maybe because i don't expect flowers at
nine in the morning
when do you expect flowers at what time
of the day
that's why if someone was standing there
with a bouquet of flowers
i'm assuming that there's a gun in that
[ __ ]
bouquet of flowers because i'm a high
profile character you know what i mean
so they're going to point that flower at
me shoot me i'm a doctor
i'm gonna die like terminator yep so
what i should do
is when they're at the front door i
should go from the back door or go to
the front
and be like what brings you to the
neighborhood
you can turn around and be like oh [ __ ]
i've been had and
he'll be like i'm here to make a
delivery and i'm like oh really maintain
yours this
distance cause it's corona time but now
you're not protected by your house
cause now you're outside of your house
yeah but i could run fast as [ __ ]
so you gotta put the gun but you have to
buzz yourself in then if you go around
i hope you left the door unlocked no no
i can't live from the back
my house my house my house no no he
doesn't live in an apartment
he lives in his house god he gotta get
out of the house i jumped i didn't need
to jump the gate
i have the keys to the game i'll be
outside i'll be i'll be like what are
you doing neighbor
he doesn't know it's my house ah
wait unless he knows you yeah you're
high profile remember
did you forget your high profile but if
they're if we're this far even if this
far
i could easily no you can't no you can't
you can't i could already tell how you
played games as a kid
you can't ah i got caught you put it on
yourself
buy a cable come on i won't come off
he's high profile see that's what you
would have caught me off guard and i
would have been like oh
damn you would have got me man if you
were the hat bandit [ __ ] that
rose the band i should have thrown it
away but i couldn't
i couldn't resist you caught it and then
you put it on i put it on i got the
glues on me man
so all [ __ ] is a nice hat [ __ ]
damn you would have caught me dude what
about this though what if you had a
snake
in a hat right and then you [ __ ] put
it on someone's head
yeah my mom's are just a snake no glue
no and then this the snake bites you
because you hide it in the hat and you
go tada [ __ ] ah
poison you know poison
oh that girl is
poisoned yeah anyway
back to this so luckily marcelo is
perfectly
fine [ __ ] perfectly hot again oh
she's
fine i bet you the colombian lady's like
no how did she get hotter
[ __ ] karma [ __ ] columbia ladies like us
maybe this will help me yeah she got fun
i don't know i mean she could just put
on a wig
she doesn't need to she's fine as [ __ ]
good i mean like if she
being bald is not a big like it's not
like oh you're hideous like she's still
a beautiful person
second degree burns yeah it's pretty bad
i get what you mean it's like
it's not a crazy like it's a kind of a
relatively easy fix to put a wig on
yeah it's not like when when people get
[ __ ] up with acid
you know how like they do that as a
rematch
all over your [ __ ] face yeah and then
like if your head looks like deadpool
where it's like
oh [ __ ] and the scar tissue hers is
just freddy krueger yeah hers is just
like little marks she still has her hair
it's gonna grow out yeah she's got these
cool scars now where it's like looks
even hotter because you think she was
like an ex super villain or something
and you're like
okay true you know what's good marcella
she's gonna look like olivia munn right
there
with bigger titties though way bigger
titties her titties are big
let's admire those there we go she
wanted you to she put them in there for
a reason
is that what they do yup i mean you see
them so i mean what do you think is
going to happen if you put them out
there people are going to see it like
this
she could have cropped it yeah she could
have done a one one square ratio
yeah better on instagram look she knows
what she got
flaunt it this is a good this is this
has to be a part of it
like when i see pictures of girls and
then it's like
the bottom boob has to be there but half
of their forehead
can be cut yeah you know what her
priorities are
yeah her nose i have i have come across
those moments
where i'm like where should i crop this
okay
the boobs are gone forehead stays in
nah the other way
i need about a little space above my
[Music]
head
[Music]
you
[Music]